Good morning, John
Being awake is awful
I feel like a poo-poo
Goodbye Lemons...
Hank: I miss you already.
Well, our taxi driver was very nice. He nearly
killed us. We almost died. But we're alive.
Uh huh.
Missoula just got this sweet outdoor lounge
area at the airport. I'm outside and there's
a plane! You're all grey speckled walls, I'm
like, "Check me out! I'm outside; there's
a plane behind me," you gotta find cooler
spots at airports. If I go this way there's
the control tower; it's cool! Apparently I've
chippered up a little bit now that I found
this amazing place.
So I'm headed to Chicago for tour. I just
went through security with $2,000 in two-dollar
bills. They didn't even ask! If you're coming
to see us, if you buy merch in cash, we'll
be giving you change in two dollar bills,
at least while supplies last. Also available,
aside from change, is this new flash drive
thing that I made that has every song I've
ever recorded or released. Even the terrible
ones. And some other various stuff. Ah, so
that's an interesting idea, 'cause CDs, how
do you even use those anymore?
For people who aren't going to be on tour,
though, I also have something to sell to you.
John and I have had this argument about Batman
and whether he's worthwhile, so for the next
week we have two shirts available: one for
my perspective - it says, "We are all bat
people!", and one, John, is from your perspective
and it says, "Batman is just a rich guy with
an affinity for bats." So to find out what
side Nerdfighteria is on, we're selling both
of them and then we're gonna count and see
whether we are, indeed, all bat people - or,
you know, which design people liked better.
John, congratulations on your golden bucket
of popcorn, that's weird - that's just - weird.
That's weird. And, yes, my butt is freezing.
This is not a warm place for my butt to be,
but I'm gonna do it!
The rest of this video, because I want you
to be entertained, is just gonna be interesting
facts about marriage.
Fact number one: The two people who played
Ferris Bueller's parents in Ferris Bueller's
Day Off met on set - and then got married!
Also they had kids and they didn't name any
of them Ferris, which is unacceptable.
Fact number two: Of the 19 couples brought
together by the television show Bachelor,
none of them are still together, which is
really, I guess, not a super surprise, but
it is interesting.
Fact number three: During the Crimean War,
a British shipmate, after being told to hit
the deck, instead ran forward toward a live
shell with its fuse hissing and threw it off
the side of a British naval vessel. For this
act of bravery, his captain promoted him to
lieutenant on the spot, also recommended him
for the Victoria Cross, and introduced him
to his daughter. The two later married. One
act of bravery turned out pretty well for
that guy.
Thirty years after this photograph was taken
at Walt Disney World, this little girl and
this little boy got married. They didn't even
live in the same country at the time - not
at the time they got married, at the time
the picture was taken.
Speaking of Disney: the guy who was for thirty-six
years the voice of Mickey Mouse was married
to the woman who was the voice of Minnie Mouse.
Also weird: David Tennant got married to an
actress who played his daughter in Doctor
Who - but the weird part of this is that she
was the actual daughter of a man who played
the Doctor in Doctor Who.
John, there are so many people in the world
that weird coincidences are bound to happen,
and in fact it has happened many times that
childhood pen pals have met later in life
and gone on to get married. But what is exceptionally
weird is when those two people are Carey Mulligan
and the dude from Mumford and Sons. They were
childhood pen pals, and then they both independently
became famous, and then they reconnected later
in life and got married.
The universe is weird! People who are coming
to see me on tour, I'm really looking forward
to it, thank you; it's gonna be a great show.
John, we are all bat people - and I'll see
you on Tuesday.
I felt bad for the poor people 'cause when
we gave them a tip they had to sing a song.
Oh hey there! Hom-nom-nom-nom.
Hello Mrs. Wainwright. It is a pleasure to
meet you, thank you for taking this opportunity.
I will really, I think I'm perfect for this
position.
Katherine: Wiggle that butt, kitty. Wiggle
it. Yeah.
Wiggle it!
Yea!